cnn's decision to fire anchor chris
cuomo has not ended the questions
surrounding his actions he was let go
saturday after new revelations about his
role in defending his brother former new
york governor andrew cuomo from sexual
harassment claims as jerika duncan
reports chris cuomo says this was not
how he wanted his time at cnn to end
this situation is unlike anything
i could have imagined chris cuomo was
one of cnn's most popular anchors i love
you very much thank you for coming on
the show but after multiple women
accused then governor andrew cuomo of
sexual misconduct chris cuomo did not
acknowledge the scandal on his show and
was later found to have advised his
brother's team on its response something
cuomo apologized for in august it was a
unique situation being a brother to a
politician in a scandal and being part
of the media
i tried to do the right thing but last
week's release of documents from the new
york attorney general's office showed
the younger cuomo was far more involved
in his brother's strategy and defense
and on tuesday cnn suspended him by
saturday cuomo was fired in a statement
a cnn spokesperson said we had cause to
terminate when new allegations came to
us this week we took them seriously and
saw no reason to delay taking immediate
action
that allegation alleges sexual
misconduct by chris cuomo from a client
of attorney debra katz who also
represents one of the women alleging
sexual misconduct by andrew cuomo katz
contacted cnn on wednesday the day after
cuomo was suspended what was it that
ultimately led to the firing of chris
cuomo i think it very much depends what
angle you look at it from david
folkenflik is a media reporter for npr
there's no way to disentangle the firing
of chris cuomo from the nature of the
allegation lodged against him several
days ago the fact that it was actually a
sexual harassment accusation against
this major tv star
whose journalistic fault
was
game planning and strategizing to
protect the political career of his
brother
when it was enveloped by accusations of
sexual harassment
a spokesperson for chris cuomo called
the misconduct allegations untrue adding
if the goal in making these false and
unvetted accusations was to see mr cuomo
punished by cnn that may explain his
unwarranted termination i think a lot of
people here had questions about
credibility i mean there's a lot more
even that we don't know about
but enough that cnn felt they had to
make a move
you don't abuse your position in
journalism for personal or financial
gain his brother was being accused of
sexual misconduct you don't use your
position as a reporter to
even if people think it's family first
shouldn't do it does appear to be
getting a little messy now yeah
the more we hear about the story the
messier it gets so we will see to be
continued for sure
good to see you good to see you thank
you